Sherri's writing in I'm making groups in
my email contact so when I want to email
one group to target everything it's in
order to start would it be benefit to
send out manually sounds like she's just
doing things through or email program
instead of using any SP right yep yep so
I think you know what when it comes to
signs that tells you that it's time to
potentially invest excuse me an email
service provider it's when you're doing
things manually like like described here
so if you're bc and seeing bc seen your
contacts you know from an Outlook or
from a gmail environment you know
investing in an ESP you know whether
it's just trying something for free for
30 days may be worth doing to identify
the time it's going to save you but then
also the power and the you know the
ability to send more than just one it
may take you what takes you five hours
now may take you one hour and then you
can do more of that within the five
hours you may a lot to focusing on email
yeah I love and you know a few thoughts
that I have here is uh one if you just
send an email through a BCC it's super
unperson alized right people are not
really going to read it where if you if
you can customize and put their name in
then people are much more likely to read
and feel like it's it's for them to you
have limits this is what I struggled
with when i first started and what I
switch to getting an email service
provider uh you can only send so many
emails out before you start getting
limited from your email provider you
could do mail merges i usually do mail
merges through my outlook but then i'm
with rogers internet and i can only send
x amount per hour then they sort of
happy me and then the other thing that i
really find helpful is a weber has this
tool that helps you determine whether an
email will go to spam or not yeah which
i find super helpful so whatever message
that you want to send you plug in their
first and it will say listen this has a
high spam score because you use these
three words and if you take out those
war
was a replacing with something else that
may seem super trivial and easy to you
but that might increase the chance of
your email getting into those people's
email inboxes by an insane percentage uh
and so once i saw that feature today
we're like i got a good side and then
just managing just you know the ability
to unsubscribe right you you can't just
span people there has a way for them to
unsubscribe from your list they don't to
here for you anymore so there's so many
reasons to move to an email service
provider um and it doesn't have to cost
a lot right I mean what does aweber
start this is a free trial but then at a
base what are we looking at for a weber
$19 up to 500 subscribers and if you
think about it you know if there's you
know the if you're serious about growing
your business and you have you know not
everyone's selling something first not
everyone is selling something you know
terms of product or a widget but if you
think about the value that can come from
just a $19 investment it's really
conversations we find ourselves just in
knowing the space and talking
entrepreneurs is your IP and your
knowledge is something that is worth it
can be monetized so for nineteen dollars
as a starting point that's very easy for
businesses to get that back over time
and it shouldn't take you know maybe you
give yourself a three to six-month
window to create some IP whether it's a
PDF or something that is that is a value
to your audience that for nineteen
dollars it's something you can sell and
that is easily going to offset the cost
of the ESP yeah I think honestly as soon
as your list gets like 25 people you're
emailing more than 25 people at a time
I'd be looking at getting some software
cuz it's just not worth the headache and
hassle correct